The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we have
organized three lectures.
And the basic idea
of the lectures
are to cover some of
the major current issues
in nuclear arms control
and nonproliferation.
So we have the first lecture
today on India and Pakistan,
which is one of the world's
possible flash points,
meaning that there's a path to
a possible nuclear war, which
I won't go into Vipin Narang
will certainly spell out
the case.
But in my view in trying to
decide what to talk about,
this was a golden opportunity
because Vipin is here,
and he's an expert
on these issues.
And I consider this, as I
say, one of the possible flash
points in the world, one of
the possible conceivable paths.
No path is super likely, if
you want to put it that way.
But the effects of
a nuclear exchange
are catastrophic both for the
people who get hit, obviously,
because a nuclear weapon--
I don't have to tell you--
is incredibly destructive.
In Hiroshima, something
like 40% of the population
was killed, more or less
instantly, burns or blasts.
And probably another
20%, 30% died
within a year of radiation.
So in addition,
people have realized
that there are severe climate
effects of a nuclear exchange.
One of the things that happens
with all the burning that
goes on is that soot is
emitted into the atmosphere.
This is the opposite
of global warming.
This is global cooling.
This is like a
volcanic explosion.
And in about 1815, 1816,
there was a volcanic explosion
in Asia.
And there was a
winter without-- there
was a summer-- excuse me--
there was a summer without crops
in Europe.
And there was actually
starvation in Europe
due to this explosion.
It was a one time thing.
The climate models, for
even a limited nuclear war
in Southeast Asia, show that
this effect would probably
last 5 to 10 years
and be global,
from roughly 100
nuclear weapons.
So there are papers.
I can give people
references if they want.
There is a paper
in Physics Today
a few years ago about this.
But there are many
papers on the subject.
So one of the things I want
to say-- so the second lecture
will be on proliferation
and uranium enrichment
and the implications.
So these lectures will combine
both technology and policy.
And finally, the last
lecture I will give--
and it's kind of an overview of
where we stand on nuclear arms
control and
proliferation-- I'll try
to fill in some of the gaps.
I'll talk about the
nonproliferation review that's
coming up at the UN next spring.
I'll talk about the outlook
for arms control as I see it.
I want to talk a few
minutes to the students
because one of the things
that's happened over
the last few decades, since
the collapse of the Soviet
Union in about 1990,
people stopped worrying
about the bomb, so to speak.
Before that, there
was a lot of concern.
Students were asked to duck
under their desks and things
like that to protect themselves,
which, of course, was totally
ridiculous.
A wooden desk wouldn't do you
much good in a nuclear war
as you can well imagine.
It'll just probably knock you
on the head with something.
God knows what it would do.
But the issue has
fallen off the table.
And the thing that
concerns people
more on campus when-- if they
think about global issues,
is climate change
and global warming.
But this is an issue
which has not gone away.
If anything, the probability
of a nuclear exchange
is higher now than a
decade ago unfortunately.
And we have not
solved these problems.
And there are political
and economic problems.
And I just want
to say a few words
about some of the
intellectual problems that
need to be solved.
For example, on a
technical basis,
there are inspection issues.
For example, how do you
inspect whether or not
a country is cheating on its
nonproliferation obligations?
How do you look for
weapons production
or enrichment production?
These are very difficult issue,
and they're very difficult
technical issues.
And then there are
issues in which
you have to combine
technical issues with policy.
For example, if we're
going to go down
to a very small
number of weapons--
as you want to do
for nuclear arms
control-- then cheating
with a small number--
particularly if
you're going to go
to 0-- cheating with a small
number becomes a bigger issue.
So verification issues are
very important, reinventing
the bomb, if you
really want to zero.
So there are all kinds
of intellectual issues
that need to be worked out,
both historical, technical,
and political.
And there are many opportunities
for research in these areas,
UROP, some theses.
So I just want to
point that out.
And there are also positions
in government and NGOs.
In the last semester, we
had several major arms
control negotiators
in the US government,
including Rose
Gottemoeller who was
the chief negotiator on the US
side for the New START Treaty,
said she was particularly
excited to give a talk at MIT
because we really needed a
generation of technically
trained people to go into
nuclear arms control.
And she made a special plea,
so I want to pass that along.
So I'm going to get
to today's lecture.
Vipin Narang, he's a professor
at the MIT political science
department and the
Security Studies program.
He's got a BS and MS in
chemical engineering.
He's got a degree
from Balliol College,
where I spent a very
happy semester at Oxford.
And he's written extensively
on nonproliferation and issues
of arms control, deterrence,
particularly with respect
to Southeast Asia.
And he's got a book
recently published
on regional powers and
international conflict.
So Vipin?
VIPIN NARANG: Great.
Thanks Aaron.
Thanks for the kind introduction
and for organizing this.
So as Aaron said,
I'm a professor
at the political
science department,
and I work primarily on nuclear
strategy and proliferation.
And so what I
thought I'd do today
was talk about--
give an overview
of nuclear proliferation and the
consequences of proliferation
in South Asia, between
India and Pakistan, which
is-- as Aaron mentioned-- an
active and ongoing conflict
where the threat of
conventional war is persistent.
And there are periodic
militarized crises
between India and Pakistan
that put both countries
at a risk of conventional
conflict every now and then.
And now that both sides, both
states, have nuclear weapons,
the question is what the
likelihood of escalation
to nuclear level is.
Just as a preview of my
own thinking and writing
on the subject, I think India
and Pakistan have so far
been lucky in that the
conventional conflict is not
yet escalated to
the nuclear level.
But that's not a foregone
conclusion going forward.
I'll talk a little
bit about that.
And it's one of
the regions where
there is still
active arms racing
between India and Pakistan.
And so I'll talk a
little bit about that
and what the dynamics have been
with the nuclear strategies
and what the effects on the
relationship between India
and Pakistan are.
If you have any questions
at all during lecture,
don't hesitate to stop me.
I know there are diverse
backgrounds here,
people from different
departments, undergraduates,
graduate students.
I'll go through some basic
theoretical material first.
If everybody's OK
with that, we can
move through that
pretty quickly and talk
about India and Pakistan.
So as I said, India and
Pakistan are both in the process
of building up their
nuclear delivery systems
and their nuclear arsenals.
This is a picture of a
Shaheen missile, which
is a Pakistani long-- it's a
medium range ballistic missile
in the Pakistani inventory.
And it's based off of a Chinese
export missile, the M-class
exports.
And both are actively testing
short and long range cruise
and ballistic missiles as
their inventories are growing.
And that is one of
the concerns, I think,
as we talk about South Asia.
The basic puzzle
though is-- does anyone
know what these
pictures are from.
So in November, November
26, 2008-- two weeks
before my wife and I
got married in Delhi
actually-- a group nominally
a sponsored and based
in Pakistan, the
Lashkar-e-Taiba,
orchestrated a pretty
daring sea-launch attack
against Bombay where about a
dozen militants, led by the one
survivor from the militant
group Ajmal Kasab pictured here,
sieged the Taj Hotel, the
Oberoi Hotel, the Chabad
House in Bombay and killed over
170 Indians and Westerners.
And the Indian government
was faced with the decision
about how to respond to this.
This was the third provocation
that the Indian government
believe was sponsored
by Pakistan since 1998,
the year in which they
tested nuclear weapons.
And the question
facing Indian leaders,
how do we respond
to a state that
sponsors militant attacks
against our metropolitan--
or metropoles,
targets our hotels
and our financial center, when
they have nuclear weapons?
And the worry in the
Indian government
was that nuclear weapons had
emboldened Pakistan to sponsor
these groups who were
perpetrating more daring
and audacious attacks
against India.
And because Pakistan
had nuclear weapons,
India didn't have a
conventional retaliatory option
to punish Pakistan
for these attacks.
And so the Indian
government, for a decade,
has been trying to deal
with what they believe
is a policy paralysis about
dealing with a Pakistan that
is more willing to support
militant organizations
to attack India now that
it has nuclear weapons.
So brief outline of the talk.
I'll talk a little bit about
basic deterrence theory.
In political science
and in economics,
the core of nuclear strategy,
both in the Cold War and now,
is deterrence theory.
So we'll talk a
little bit about that.
Hopefully, it's not too basic.
I don't need to talk about
the basics of nuclear weapons
to a physics audience.
We'll go through
it really briefly,
and some of the choices
states have to make
and how they operationalize
their arsenal, which
are really important in the
India and Pakistan context.
I'll talk about the
causes of and the process
of nuclearization in South Asia,
how and why India and Pakistan
acquired nuclear weapons.
And then I'll close
with the consequences
and where we are
today, focusing mostly
on the period since 1990.
May 1998 is the break point
in the India, Pakistan
nuclear equation.
That's when India, led by
the then BJP government,
tested nuclear weapons,
followed three weeks later
by the Pakistani government.
I'll close with
some conclusions.
So basic deterrence theory.
The definition of
deterrence, very simple--
this is a definition
of deterrence.
This is all inspired by guys
like Tom Schelling, Herman
Kahn, Albert Wohstetter.
Anybody familiar with
Cold War nuclear strategy,
this will be familiar to you.
So basic deterrence
theory, in any context,
is trying to preserve
the status quo
by threatening unacceptable cost
to an opponent or an adversary
if they do x, some
specified action.
So if you do x, I will do y.
And the idea is we
preserve the status quo.
And the idea is that y, the
punishment that you impose
on your adversary
opponent, should
be greater than the benefits
of them achieving whatever
their objective is,
x, such that they
are deterred from
undertaking the action.
Tom Schelling used to love
examples with children.
So I have an
18-month-old son myself,
and he's starting to
understand things.
And as children get
older, deterrence
by punishment example
that Tom Schelling used
was if your child
does something bad,
you punish them by
sending to their room,
denying them dinner, time out.
So there's some punishment
after the fact if they do x.
In another example is if you
hit me, I will kill your mother.
So there's a punitive aspect
to the deterrence threat
such that the punishment exceeds
the benefit of whatever am
adversary's objective would be.
So in the Cold War, the
deterrence by denial threat
was counterforce.
We were going to disarm and
target their own nuclear forces
to make it impossible
for them to carry out
their first strike.
So in a case where
somebody's attacking me,
a deterrence by
denial threat would
be instead of
killing your mother,
I cut you're arm off
so you can't attack me.
And presumably, the cost
of cutting your arm off,
so you cannot achieve your
objective in the first place,
is sufficient to deter
you from undertaking it.
So a good way to think about
this deterrence by punishment
is we will punish you
with such severe cost,
after you undertake the
action, such that you'll
have no incentive--
rational incentive
to do so verses we will
ratchet up the costs
while you try to achieve the
objective such that you won't
be able to in the first place.
So I think it's an
important distinction when
we think about nuclear strategy
even in the South Asia case.
But in the Cold
War, the distinction
was counterforce
versus countervalue.
So for those familiar with
Cold War nuclear strategy,
when we threatened to
target Soviet cities
or their economic or
industrial capacity,
that was largely a deterrence
by punishment strategy.
So in the event
that they launched
a conventional or a first
nuclear strike against us,
we would retaliate
against their cities.
The alternative was, and
this was a big debate
early in the Cold War, in a
case of a conventional conflict,
we would launch nuclear weapons
at their nuclear weapons
such that they would
not have the ability
to launch those weapons at the
United States or its allies.
So the deterrence theory has
several basic requirements.
We call them the three C's.
So you need to
have the capability
to impose the threat
that you're promising.
So if you're threatening to
destroy an adversary's cities
in the event they
do something, you
need to have the
capability do that.
So you need some
explosive capability,
but you also, most importantly,
in the nuclear sense,
need a delivery capability.
You need to be able
to hit their cities.
And it needs to be
transparent to the adversary.
It needs to be credible.
And this term credibility and
the concept of credibility
is what dogged Cold War strategy
and still dogs nuclear strategy
today.
Credibility is the
hardest part of this.
How could you threaten what was
tantamount to mutual suicide
and have it be credible
by your adversary?
So in the event of-- so in
the Cold War, a good example
is if the Soviet Union
took West Berlin,
was it really credible that
the United States would
threaten to launch
hundreds of nuclear weapons
at Soviet cities?
The Soviet Union
probably didn't think so.
So in a deterrence by
punishment versus deterrence
by denial trade off, which one
do you think is more credible?
So in the case where an
attacker is coming at you,
is it more credible
to threaten to kill
their mother in response
or to cut off their arm?
What is an attacker
more likely to believe?
It is disproportionate
to threaten
certain punitive action, and
so it is often more credible--
and this is where the trade
off between-- the debate early
in the Cold War about deterrence
by punishment versus deterrence
by denial turned on the
credibility differences
between the two.
That deterrence by denial
seemed to be more credible.
The adversary is more
likely to believe
that you would try to stop them
from achieving their objectives
than to kill millions
of innocent civilians
that had nothing to do with
the fight in the first place
after something had
already happened.
And so the United States
ended up threatening both.
And part of it was that
the size of the US arsenal
made it possible
to threaten both.
But I think there were
many strategists who
believed that the deterrence
by denial missions
were still more credible
to the adversary.
But at the heart of deterrence
is this issue of credibility.
And the third C
is communication.
The adversary needs
to know that you
have the capability
and the credibility
to threaten the punishment or
deterrence by denial threat
that you make.
So you have to make a threat.
IT has to be public.
The adversary has to
know what the threat is.
The adversary needs
to know what objective
you are laying a red line
down for and that you
have the capability to inflict
the punishment that you
threaten.
So there's a huge
amount of transparency
that is required for
deterrence to operate.
Has anyone seen Dr.
Strangelove, the movie?
What's the problem
with the doomsday
machine in Dr. Strangelove?
There's a great line.
What's the point of a
doomsday machine if you
don't tell anybody about it.
The adversary needs to know
that undertaking certain actions
will result in some punishment
for deterrence to operate.
So nuclear weapons and--
deterrence, as a concept,
pre-dated nuclear weapons.
The concept of
ratcheting up the cost
to trying to deter an adversary
predates nuclear weapons
by centuries, since
the dawn of warfare.
But nuclear weapons
fundamentally
alter deterrence equations
for several reasons.
One, the explosive yields,
and as Aaron mentioned,
even the Hiroshima
bomb, 20 kilotons
could kill 100,000 people.
You could kill cities, entire
cities, with a single warhead.
But more than that,
the missile age really
changed how deterrence
could operate because, prior
to nuclear weapons,
what was the most
destructive military technology
in States' inventory?
Does anyone know?
Before nuclear weapons
in World War II,
how did the United States and
Allies and Germany attack?
AUDIENCE: Strategic bombing.
VIPIN NARANG: Strategic bombing
and fire bombing, right?
And the problem was that you had
to send hundreds of airplanes
and sorties into enemy territory
to inflict that kind of damage.
So your own pilots and
air force was a risk.
Now, with the missile age,
you can launch warheads
at no risk to your pilots.
The numbers that
you were required
to destroy entire cities
were much smaller.
So you could ratchet up
the cost really quickly
without incurring much
cost yourself in the way
the strategic bombing and fire
bombing required of a state
prior to the advent
of the nuclear age.
And one shouldn't underestimate
the psychological impact
of an adversary being able
to destroy entire cities
with a single
warhead, from afar,
at very low risk to itself.
So nuclear weapons
ratchet up the ease
of imposing punishment
in ways that didn't
exist prior to the nuclear age.
So nuclear weapons fundamentally
changed deterrence equations.
Is everyone familiar with
the basics of uranium,
plutonium nuclear weapons?
So I don't need to go
through enriched uranium.
plutonium from reprocessing.
Those are basic fission weapons
and boosted fission weapon.
So what is important,
I think, is
most regional powers are
operating-- so India, Pakistan,
South Africa when they
had nuclear weapons.
A little known
fact, South Africa
had nuclear weapons
from 1979 to about 1991.
Most states start with
fission weapons, move
to boosted fission weapons.
The advanced nuclear
powers have fusion weapons.
Most of the United
States' nuclear inventory
is composed of thermo-- these
are thermonuclear weapons.
So when you think of
the A-bomb, that's
fission and boosted
fission weapons.
The H--bomb are fusion weapons.
The United States has extremely
advanced dial up, dial down
yield nuclear weapons.
But they're all
thermonuclear weapons
where there's a primary that
ignites a fusion secondary.
But most regional powers
are operating here.
So North Korea, India, Pakistan.
Israel is assumed to have
boosted fission devices.
But it's possible they
have fusion weapons.
It's unknown.
They have never
tested or acknowledged
their nuclear forces.
Well, Britain is
basically an adjunct force
of the United States.
They lease their
weapons from the United
States for their tridents, so
those are basically US weapons.
The French have fusion weapons.
But India and Pakistan are
operating in boosted fission
range.
I mean that's important.
When you can get
to megaton yields,
you are talking about
characteristically different
weapons.
The number that
would be required
to destroy an entire
city are much lower
once you have fusion weapons.
But obviously, a fission
or boosted fission device
could do a lot of
damage as well.
But once you have
nuclear warheads,
you're only halfway there
in terms of operationalizing
nuclear arsenal.
I think this is
often forgotten when
we talk about the
proliferation process.
States need more than
just nuclear weapons
and warheads-- functional
and reliable warheads--
to have a nuclear arsenal.
They need delivery
capabilities, right?
So the first
question you have is,
how many and what type
of nuclear weapons
do I want to have?
India and Pakistan are still
answering this question.
It is unclear how much is
enough for India and Pakistan.
It is unclear how much
is enough for China.
China has about-- it's
estimated in the 200 to 400
thermonuclear weapon
range arsenal size.
But faced with US
missile defenses,
conventional counterforce
capabilities,
it's unclear how much
is enough for China.
You need to be able to--
a big piece of answering
this question is-- a big
concept in the Cold War
was secure second
strike capability.
So we were worried
about-- the United
States was worried about a bolt
out of the blue first strike.
You would lose n
number of weapons.
You needed to have enough that
would be able to survive that
not only in terms of numbers,
but in deployment modes,
where they were based
and how they were based,
to be able to retaliate
back with certainty
against the Soviet Union such
that it deterred the Soviet
from trying to
undertake what is known
as the splendid first
strike in the first place.
A splendid first strike being
the ability to fully wipe out
your nuclear arsenal.
So secure second strike
capability for states is when
they achieve a level of numbers
and deployment modes such that
an adversary cannot be confident
that it could fully disarm that
state's nuclear arsenal.
Other question is, how
do you deliver them?
So most states
start with aircraft.
You've got aircraft.
You rig them to carry
nuclear weapons.
But what's the problem with
aircrafts as a nuclear delivery
capability?
AUDIENCE: You have to get inside
VIPIN NARANG: Yeah.
You have to penetrate
enemy defenses, right?
You're not going to get
there without a fight.
And so it's not the ideal
type of delivery capability.
We have strategic bombers
with huge complements
of escort aircraft.
They were not survivable.
The advantage to aircraft
is you can recall them.
They're piloted so you
can bring them back.
The disadvantage is they still
have to penetrate enemy air
forces-- air defenses.
Sorry.
So then the United States
and most regional powers
are attracted to ballistic
missiles of various types.
Ballistic missiles
have the advantage
that you can launch
them from afar.
They have different ranges,
liquid fuel, solid fuel.
It's not risky for the user.
They can't be recalled though.
But they're different
basing modes,
so you can have land-based
ballistic missiles.
We have ICBM silos in
Wyoming and North Dakota.
You can have mobile
ballistic missiles on land.
The United States
moved quickly to
sea-based ballistic
missiles, SLBMs.
Why?
Why do you think
sea-based is attractive,
at least for the United States?
AUDIENCE: The enemy can't
find them hopefully.
VIPIN NARANG: So in theory,
if your subs are quiet enough,
they are virtually
100% survivable
because they're very
difficult to track
if your subs are quiet enough.
And this was something--
there's an assumption
that once a state acquires
a sea-based capability,
it has a survivable
second strike force.
That's true probably
in the US case,
but other states' SSBNs, the
sea-based ballistic missile
nuclear submarines, are not
quiet as the United States is.
There is increasing evidence
to show that we were pretty
good at tracking Soviet SSBNs.
We're pretty good at tracking
subs during the Cold War.
I don't know how much
we track them now.
I mean you have to
assume-- Soviet SSBNs,
as the later generations
became quieter,
and we're still pretty
good at attracting them.
You can imagine first
generation Chinese SSBNs,
Indian SSBNs are
going to be so loud.
Some of them are
not nuclear powered.
They're diesel
powered, which actually
helps with the noise signature.
But it is not
necessarily the case
that all states that acquire
sea-based capabilities
are going to have
survivable second strike.
But this is the attraction
of a sea-based force.
A submarine-based
nuclear force is
more survivable than land-based
force because land-based force,
with all the [INAUDIBLE]
out there now,
you can track-- you know
where launch sites might be,
where they may flush
out land-based forces,
so then you can target them.
Increasingly, some states
led by the United States
are attracted to cruise
missiles as nuclear delivery
capabilities, Tomahawks.
We have a Tomahawk land and
air-based nuclear version.
The French have an air
launched cruise missile,
which is a mainstay of their
nuclear force structure.
India and Pakistan are also
looking at cruise missiles
because they can-- what's the
advantage of cruise missiles?
What's the worry now
with ballistic missiles?
AUDIENCE: They might
shoot them down.
VIPIN NARANG: So missile
defenses and the advent
of missile defenses is starting
to threaten the survivability
of ballistic
missiles, so one shift
is to cruise
missiles, which fly--
they have lower altitudes.
They can be more
easily controlled,
so there's more
recallability, I think,
with cruise missiles than
with ballistic missiles,
but primarily to defeat
missile defenses.
Third question is, how
do you manage them?
Some states put their nuclear
forces under military control.
Some states put them under
very firm civilian control.
This is a question the
United States wrestled
with during the Cold War.
Initially, the Department
of Atomic Energy
managed the nuclear pits
in the United States.
It was under very
firm civilian control.
And then as it became clear
that the United States would
have to delegate some actual
nuclear forces to the Army
in Western Europe for
tactical nuclear weapons,
the US arsenal came under
military management,
but still under
civilian authority.
Other states like
Pakistan are completely
under military
control, and we'll
talk a little bit about that.
But fundamentally, the
question that regional powers
in particular have
to face, in ways
that the superpowers
didn't as much as,
is what are you trying to
deter with nuclear weapons?
Why are you attracting
nuclear weapons,
and what are you using
them for in your larger
strategic policy?
So some states need
nuclear weapons
just to deter nuclear
use against them.
States, like China for example,
which have huge geographies,
3 million men under arms,
defense in depth strategy
aren't really facing
conventional threats
on land the way that the US and
Soviet Union were facing off
in Western Europe.
So China and India
both primarily
have nuclear weapons to deter
nuclear use against them.
So you are worried about
a nuclear armed adversary.
You don't want your adversary
to have nuclear weapons
and you not have the
ability to retaliate.
You're really using
nuclear weapons
to deter nuclear
use against you.
You can then rely on what we
call an assured retaliation
strategy.
You just need to be
able survive what
might be a first
strike against you
and retaliate with
nuclear weapons
against your adversaries
population centers.
This is your classic deterrence
by punishment strategy.
Nuclear weapons don't
need to be on high alert.
Retaliation doesn't
need to be immediate.
It just needs to
be certain, and you
don't need tactical
nuclear weapons
because you're not using nuclear
weapons on conventional forces
that might be attacking you.
So this allows for much
more centralized, recessed
management if that's your aim.
If your aim is to deter
conventional aggression--
this was the US and NATO
during the Cold War.
We had conventional
inferiority in Europe.
In order to offset the
conventional capability
of the Warsaw Pact
and the Soviet Union,
the United States
needed nuclear weapons--
the threat of tactical
nuclear weapons
to offset that differential.
And we needed to threaten to
use nuclear weapons first.
If Warsaw Pact nuclear
conventional forces
came crashing in
a Western Europe,
the United States
very explicitly
threatened to use
tactical nuclear weapons
against advancing
Warsaw Pact forces.
Unlike in the assured
retaliation case,
you can say, look, I have
a no first use policy.
I won't use nuclear
weapons unless you use them
against me, primarily strategic
weapons, compared to here
you have a very forward,
aggressive tactical nuclear
weapons capability
where you have
to threaten to use
nuclear weapons first
right because you're trying
to deter conventional attacks
against you.
And it looks like a
denial and punishment
mission at the same time.
And now regional powers are
faced with the same question.
Now, can anyone guess
where India falls?
Did I say it already?
Yeah.
Assured retaliation.
They have conventional
superiority against Pakistan.
They're not really
worried about China
invading India and marching
all the way to Delhi.
They're primarily trying
to deter nuclear use
against its own cities.
Where does Pakistan fall?
What is Pakistan worried about?
So Pakistan is primarily worried
about Indian conventional
superiority.
And having been at the
receiving end of dismemberment
from India in 1971,
which I'll talk about,
Pakistan has
operationalized a posture
that is very aggressive, very
oriented towards battlefield
nuclear weapons against any
conventional forces that might
cross the international border.
And so they have a first use--
I call it asymmetric escalation
doctrine.
They threaten to escalate
a conventional conflict
to the nuclear very quickly
because-- or earlier than India
would-- before any other
nuclear weapons are used
because they're worried about
Indian conventional superiority
against it.
Pakistan actually started
its nuclear program
before India tested the
so-called PNE in 1974
because on the
heels of the 1974--
I'll talk about this,
actually, right now.
So India security environment,
historically, so it
has the 1962 war
with China in which
its conventional performance
shocked even the Indian army
and the Indian leadership.
The Chinese performed so
much better than the Indians
in the '62 war, and India
decisively lost the '62 war.
Two years later, China
tested its nuclear weapons.
So the Indian military program
gets its motivation, initially,
from its experiences in
'62 and '64 with China.
And to avoid nuclear coercion
in the future against China,
India hedges under
the Nehru years
and then the subsequent
leadership under Indira Ghandi.
It does also have these
persistent wars with Pakistan.
But it has conventional
superiority,
and there was really
never any talk
about needing nuclear weapons
to deter the Pakistanis.
So India had a civilian
nuclear program.
It got a CANDU reactor Canada.
Some of the heavy waters was
supplied by the United States,
and 54 reprocessing
facilities in '64.
And then in 1974,
Indira Ghandi authorizes
what's known at the time-- under
the Atoms for Peace program,
there was a category known as
a Peaceful Nuclear Explosion,
which was-- I mean there
are legitimate uses, it
was believed at the
time, for nuclear.
Like, if you needed to
clear large swaths of land
for dams for example.
And India had some
potential uses for this,
but it didn't
really fool-- I mean
a peaceful nuclear explosion
is still a nuclear explosion.
It wasn't, however, a warhead.
I mean this thing
was a rickety--
I think was it was eight
meters in diameter device.
I mean it was a hulking,
unstable, rickety fission
device that they
tested in 1974-- it
wasn't suitable for
a military program.
It wasn't miniaturized.
It didn't have-- it was
even suitable for delivery
by aircraft.
You'd have to throw it out
the back of a cargo plane.
I mean it still gave
them, certainly,
the physics of being able
to sustain fission and have
spherical compression.
All of that was-- and it
was a plutonium device,
so it wasn't trivial.
But it wasn't a nuclear
weapon in the sense of the way
that we think of.
So a lot of work was still
yet to be done after 1974,
but it demonstrated that Indian
scientists had the ability
to at least design
rudimentary nuclear weapons.
There are several
explanations for why
it tested in '74, as
a general security
environment-- I talked about
China-- persistent wars
with Pakistan.
They had just won the 1970
war with Pakistan-- 1971 war
with Pakistan, which
split Pakistan in two.
I'll talk about that.
That was the real motivation
for the Pakistani program.
But the real explanation
is a combination
of domestic politics
and the power
of the scientists in India.
So Indira Ghandi was
facing a potential series
of losses in state governments.
She wanted a big win.
There were several very
prominent Indian physicists
and engineers who promised a big
boost in her electoral fortunes
if she tested a nuclear
weapon, and they really
wanted to test a nuclear
weapon because they
had bee working on it.
Scientists like to test the
things that they work on.
And they had been doing this
persistently for several years.
And she then found her
opportunity in 1974
when, right before a
series of state elections,
she authorized the test.
Empirically, the
test didn't actually
help her that much electorally,
but there was a belief
that it might.
And so that was some of the
motivations for the test.
From 1974 until about
1989, for about 15 years,
India's nuclear program went
into effective dormancy.
There was no high
level authorization
from Indira Gandhi, or her son
who later became prime minister
after her assassination in
1984, for the militarization
of the program.
So India's scientists
worked on some of the--
did some of the theoretical
work for miniaturization,
getting India in a place
where if it had to militarize
a program, it could.
But there was no actual physical
worked done on that after 1974.
Pakistan faced a somewhat
different security environment.
So where as India lost
the '62 war and then
faced China's nuclear test--
but never really faced
the threat of a massive
conventional invasion
from China, really
wanting nuclear weapons
to deter the Chinese
nuclear threat, not
the Chinese
conventional threat--
Pakistan was really
scarred by the 1971 war.
So the 1971 war was the
war in which East Pakistan
was birthed into Bangladesh.
So there was a refugee
crisis the West Pakistan
and East-- so Pakistan
at birth, in 1947,
was split non-contiguous
with India in the middle.
You had East and West Pakistan.
West Pakistan was
dominated by Punjab.
East Pakistan was dominated
by Bangladeshis-- Bengalis.
Sorry.
Later Bangladeshis.
Bengalis.
So there was ethnic tension
between Punjabis and Bengalis.
The Punjabis dominated
the politics of Pakistan.
Bengalis felt like
they were second class
citizens in Pakistan.
That created political tension.
And there was an
uprising in 1971.
India intervened on
behalf of the Bengalis
to split East Pakistan
off of a West Pakistan.
Now, if you're India, this is a
huge strategic victory, right?
You had two flanks of
Pakistan surrounding you,
and you were able to make
them two independent countries
with the benefit that you helped
birth Bangladesh from Pakistan.
So it's not like
they would be allies
against you in a conflict.
So strategically this worked
out pretty well for India.
But for West Pakistan,
now present day Pakistan,
this was a pretty scary moment.
Your east wing is
amputated, and it was
at the hands of the Indians.
So as early as 1965,
when it became clear
that India might look at nuclear
weapons because of China,
Zulfikar Ali Bhutto, who was
the prime minister that ended up
authorizing the program
through the 1970s,
said "we will eat grass or
leaves or even go hungry,
but we will get a
bomb of our own."
It's one of his famous quotes.
Remember, this was
said as early as 1965.
But after the 1971
war-- in January 1972,
so right after 1971 war, Bhutto
authorizes the nuclear weapons
program with express intent of
a militarized nuclear weapons
program to deter Indian
conventional power.
So it wasn't because of the
Indian PNE, which was 1974.
Pakistan's nuclear
weapons program
predates India's 1974 test.
The real motivation
was the 1971 war.
Pakistan could not suffer
the conventional defeat
at the hands of
the Indians again.
And so Pakistan's nuclear
program was triggered.
For a state that was essentially
desperate for nuclear weapons,
Pakistan tried all
possible avenues.
So you had the uranium pathway,
which was led by AQ Khan.
Everyone's familiar
with AQ Khan?
Yes we Khan?
Horrible, horrible joke.
I apologize.
So he essentially stole
the URENCO designs.
URENCO is a European consortium.
He stole it from
the Netherlands.
He worked at URENCO.
From the inside, he
stole the blueprints
for what ended up being the P1.
And then he modified it
later to be P2 designs.
So he stole the
URENCO centrifuge
designs from URENCO itself
where he was an employee.
He went back to
Bhutto and said, look,
I can deliver a nuclear
weapons program.
And they set up cascades
of the P1s at Kahuta,
which Pakistan would
deny through the 1980s,
was a uranium
enrichment facility.
The then president,
General Zia, referred to it
as a goat shed repeatedly in
interactions with the United
States.
The problem was what
happened in 1979?
Charlie Wilson's War, anyone?
AUDIENCE: Iran.
VIPIN NARANG: Well, also Iran.
OK, that's true.
You had the Iran Hostage Crisis
and the revolution in Iran.
But you also had what
else, December 1979?
AUDIENCE: Soviet invasion.
VIPIN NARANG: Yes,
Christmas invasion.
So the Soviets
invade Afghanistan.
And all of a sudden, Pakistan
is America's-- one of the most
useful countries in the
world for the United States
because the United
States decides to supply
the mujahideen in Afghanistan
to fight the Soviets.
How do you get supplies
to the mujahideen?
You have to route
them through Pakistan.
That's when the relationship
between Pakistan and the United
States flourished because
we really had no option.
History doesn't repeat
itself, but it rhymes.
We did the exact same
thing in the 2000s.
And when we were at
war in Afghanistan,
we needed the ground lines of
communication through Pakistan.
And the relationship between the
ISI and the CIA in the 1980s,
because of the US
role in Afghanistan,
became-- what's the right
word for it-- blossomed.
But there was always tension
in that relationship.
But due to US nonproliferation
legislation in Congress,
the United States would
have been obligated
to sanction Pakistan
and cut off all aid
if Pakistan were to
assemble a nuclear weapon.
Remember, Pakistan
and India never
signed the Nuclear
Nonproliferation Treaty.
US legislation required
that a state that was not
a member of the
Non-Proliferation Treaty
found with nuclear weapons--
or who had nuclear weapons,
would face immediate
sanctions cut off of US aid.
But that threatened US
operations in Afghanistan,
so that couldn't happen.
So there was a lot of tension
between the nonproliferation
hawks at the state
department and the executive.
So the Reagan administration
went to great lengths
to play fast and loose
on where Pakistan
was with its nuclear program.
Everybody knew that Pakistan
had a nuclear weapons program.
But the wording of the
language of the legislation
required-- and it
later embodied in what
was known as the
Solarz Amendment
that the US presence
certify that Pakistan
doesn't have nuclear weapons.
So as long as the
executive-- and the executive
defined nuclear weapons as the
assembly of a nuclear weapon.
So as long as Pakistan
did not cross that line,
the executive could
certify that Pakistan
was a non-nuclear weapon state.
And therefore, the aid and the
relationship between the US
and Pakistan could continue.
AUDIENCE: When you say
Pakistan, is this so east
and west are actually
separate countries?
VIPIN NARANG: So
Bangladesh, at this point,
is an independent country after
1970-- so this is west-- this
is Pakistan, Pakistan,
present day Pakistan.
And this is with Zia.
Zia is the president general.
He executed Bhutto in 1979
I think also, '77 or '79.
And he's the present of
Pakistan during the 1980s.
And we'll get through
the-- there's a slow march
to nuclearization
So '83, there's
some Chinese assistance to
the Pakistani nuclear program.
In fact, on precedent, I think,
in the annals of proliferation,
China transferred--
is now, I think, out
in declassified documents,
the United States believes,
and i think Pakistan has
admitted, that they received 50
kilograms of HEU from Pakistan.
That's effectively two
bombs worth of HEU.
Assuming 25 kilograms
a per bomb--
two bombs worth of HEU
from China plus the design
for uranium core warhead,
known as CHIC-4 design.
It was the fourth test in
the Chinese test series.
So that's 1983.
By 1986, the US is
essentially convinced
that Pakistan is a
nuclear capable state.
But remember, it
had it certified
as a non-nuclear weapons state.
So they were two
screwdriver turns away,
you could certify them as a
non-nuclear weapons state.
And the executive
continued to do that.
In March 1987, Zia
complicates all
of this when he claims that
Pakistan has the capability
to make a bomb in Time magazine.
So all of the nonproliferation
hawks go nuts.
Here, you have the
president of Pakistan
saying to Time magazine that
Pakistan-- he literally said,
you could write Pakistan has
the capability to make a bomb,
and they did.
And it was then that
congressman Stephen Solarz
passed the Solarz
amendment where
the president had to
actually certify Pakistan
not a nuclear weapon state.
But the language he
put in there made
it easier for the president
to be able to say that and not
be lying because the language
is basically nuclear device.
So if the device
wasn't assembled,
the executive could legitimately
claim that Pakistan did not
have a nuclear weapon.
Even though it had
the pit over there,
the explosive package over
here, the assembly over here,
but it would all be on
three sides of the room.
But you could certify
that it wasn't assembled,
so it wasn't a nuclear weapon.
And so by 1988, the
nonproliferation hawks
had given up, and Solarz
quipped that it had a Saturday
night special capability.
It may not be elegant,
but it'll do the job.
And one of the advantages to
the Pakistani nuclear weapons
program was, given
the fact that they
had a tested design
from the Chinese,
they conducted a series of
cold tests in the 1980s.
But they didn't have to
necessarily conduct a hot test
to know that their
weapons would work,
unlike the Indians who
were indigenously designing
their plutonium devices.
So by the late 1980s, Pakistan
is a nuclear weapons capable
state.
In fact, the War in Afghanistan
ends around 1989, 1990.
President George H
W Bush is president.
And as soon as the US stops--
as soon as the Cold War
collapse-- sorry-- the
Soviet Union collapses,
President H W Bush
refuse to certify
Pakistan as a non-nuclear
weapon states anymore.
AUDIENCE: You talk
a out cold test.
What constitutes a cold test?
VIPIN NARANG: A cold test is
without the fissile material.
So you--
AUDIENCE: Do they really
know that it works?
VIPIN NARANG:
Especially in this case,
it's a spherical compression.
So they wanted to, as they were
testing the explosive charges,
make sure they get a
uniform compression wave.
Because they weren't using--
it's a uranium device,
but they weren't
designing contact devices.
It was still an implosion.
It was a uranium
implosion device.
And so you could do a cold test
without the fissile material
to make sure that you had
a uniform compression.
So you can do a
sufficient number of tests
without the fissile material.
And since the design itself
was tested in a hot test,
I think the Pakistanis
were quite confident
that once they had enough
fissile material in the design,
it would work.
So in this period, remember,
India is in dormancy.
But there's a-- in response to
Zia's claim in Time magazine
and several other statements,
India brings its program out
of dormancy in
response, actually,
to Pakistan's program.
So there's a narrative--
the conventional wisdom
is that India's
nuclear program beget
Pakistan's nuclear program.
But it's the other way around.
So Pakistan's
program is triggered
by Indian conventional power.
India has this rudimentary
nuclear hedging program
in the 1970s.
It was only when
Pakistan claimed publicly
that it had a nuclear weapons
capability that India brings
its program out of dormancy.
So it was only in 1988, 1989--
it was actually winter of 1989.
Then Prime Minister
Rajiv Gandhi orders
work on weaponization,
miniaturization, production
line, all the things you need
to have a military program.
And India only is starting
then, at that point, racing
to develop delivery capability.
So they had indigenous
missiles, the Agni
and the Prithvi missile.
And so India was playing
from behind in this period.
So it would take India
another four or five years
before they would have
a militarized program
that they could test.
Once they reached
that point, there
were several aborted tests.
1995, Prime Minister Rao
of the Congress Party,
he is on the brink of tests.
And the US Ambassador,
Frank Wisner
goes to Prime
Minister Rao and says,
we know you're about to test.
Don't do it.
The weight of American
sanctions will kill you,
and Rao backs off.
A couple months later, the
BJP, which is the opposition
party-- the main opposition
party at the time,
when's office for
the first time.
They're in office
for only 13 days,
so they have to pull
back from the test
that they were
planning to conduct.
When they return to
power in May 1998,
the BJP, in its
manifesto, says it's
going to test nuclear weapons.
Yet the CIA claims it
was caught off guard
when they came back
to power after they
had ordered tests in 1996.
Everyone claims that the
CIA was caught off guard
by the May 1998 test.
But the BJP had said it publicly
that if they came into office,
they were going to test
nuclear weapons again.
And they did take
steps to camouflage
the activity in the test sites.
But as soon as they come back
to office, two months after they
win office in a
permanent majority,
they test nuclear weapons.
It was five fission devices.
They cited everything
under the sun,
but primarily,
China's the reason
for testing nuclear weapons.
And then the question
was, how does India, now
that they overly
tested nuclear weapons,
operationalize its
nuclear capabilities?
As I mentioned before, India has
an assured retaliation posture.
So it tested nuclear
weapons in 1998,
and then the question is, how
do we manage these things?
India very quickly decided to
have a no first use policy.
And they were going to have
a very assertive management
of their nuclear forces and
rely on an assured retaliation
capability, so no tactical
nuclear weapons, just
strategic weapons.
The capability is
under civilian custody,
and the aim of their doctrine
is to deter nuclear use
against Indian
population centers.
So it's a deterrent by
punishment strategy.
And they have long range
ballistic missiles.
They had some
aircraft capability,
but they're primarily moving
a missile capability now.
And they have very
recessed posture,
very few weapons on alert.
Most of the arsenal is actually
disassembled during peace time.
Some subset is at higher
states of readiness,
but it's primarily-- it
would take several steps
up the alert ladder before
India is in a position
to use nuclear weapons.
So they're not on
hair trigger alert
as American and
Soviet weapons were.
Pakistan, on the other hand--
so it tests shortly after India.
They have moved away
from uranium enrichment
to plutonium.
For the physicists here, what's
the advantage of plutonium?
Plutonium weapons.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VIPIN NARANG: Right.
So the yield-to-weight
ratio is much better.
So if you want battlefield
nuclear weapons or higher yield
strategic weapons, and you
have payload constraints--
you're trading off
range for payload,
so a plutonium gets you much
better yield-to-weight ratios.
So it is about 4 to 1 advantage.
And once they had
the uranium devices,
they're worried--
Pakistan was always
worried that India would
attack its nuclear facilities.
Once it acquired basic
nuclear weapons capability
through the uranium pathway, now
it doesn't fear that as much.
And so most of the plutonium
production is out in the open
and with Chinese help.
So there are series
of Chinese reactors
and reprocessing facilities
that are coming on line.
And Pakistan is shifting
to plutonium production,
primarily for its battlefield
nuclear weapons capability.
It's delivery capabilities
were initially
bought from China
and North Korea,
so there were missiles for
uranium enrichment capability
trade that Pakistan had with
China-- sorry-- with North
Korea.
So it got the No-Dong
missiles from North Korea.
In exchange, North
Korea got some basis
for its uranium enrichment
capability that it now has.
And China also sold
Pakistan some MX-4 missiles,
which are the Shaheen and
Gaznavi missiles for Pakistan.
AUDIENCE: What's the motivation
for China to sell and give
this aid to Pakistan?
VIPIN NARANG: Well, so
if you're China, what's
the advantage of having
Pakistan be nuclear
and-- who's in the middle?
Look at thee-- They can
sandwich India, right?
So the enemy of my
enemy is my friend.
AUDIENCE: I mean it seams China
had their own nuclear weapons,
so anything from Pakistan
would be trivial.
Pakistan's a little unstable.
You never quite know if the
government collapses, what
might happen to those weapons.
VIPIN NARANG: No, I mean these
are all reasonable questions.
And I think they're raised
of the Chinese a lot.
Like that you provide a
state a nuclear capability
or assist them, but you don't
want to take responsibility
if there's a fracture in the
state and nuclear weapons
fall into extremist hands.
And the Chinese
will always-- you
go to some of these Track
IIs and China has always
washed their hands of it.
But you can think from
a strategic perspective
why it makes sense for them to
have India focused on Pakistan,
and this is one way to do.
And I think that's the
Chinese motivation.
So Pakistan,
because it is trying
to deter Indian
conventional power,
has an explicit
first use doctrine.
And this has evolved in
the past 15, 16 years.
First of all, it's
credible because all
of Pakistan's nuclear weapons
are under military custody.
Unlike India where the
civilian custody and control
of nuclear weapons, Pakistan
is a de facto praetorian state.
The Army is a dominant
decision making body.
And so all the nuclear weapons
program, from cradle to grave,
is under army management.
So they control the
nuclear weapons program.
There's been a shift to
battlefield nuclear weapons.
There's a capability
known as the NASR missile.
If anyone's been following
this, it's a 60 kilometer,
short range nuclear
weapon system
that will be fielded at the
rear edge of battle that
would target Indian
forces if they
cross the international border.
They have a series of cruise
missiles, which are also
designed to be battlefield
nuclear weapons, the Ra'ad
and the Babur.
And they have an explicitly
deterrence by denial mission.
They're trying to deter
Indian conventional attacks
across the international border.
So there are some--
any questions
about where we are in terms of
how India and Pakistan think
about nuclear weapons
in their force postures?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Around that time
was India suggesting at all
that that they were
interested in traditional war
with Pakistan?
VIPIN NARANG: So this is
an excellent question.
Why would Pakistan-- I'll
skip through some of this
because the crux of the
problem now is India
doesn't have any territorial
designs on Pakistan.
Why would India want to
dismember Pakistani further?
It prefers a stable Pakistan.
It has no territorial
ambitions in Pakistan.
There are some-- Kashmir
is a disputed-- there's
a dispute over Kashmir.
But frankly, the line
of control on both sides
is effectively the
de facto border.
There won't be much territorial
revision over Kashmir.
And certainly, if you're worried
about a conventional attack
across the international
border, how do you get there?
I'll get to that in one second
after very quickly talking
about, in the
nuclear sense, what
the difference is between
South Asian the Cold War.
So both sides now
have nuclear weapons.
Some of the key differences
between India, Pakistan,
and the United States
and the Soviet Union
are, one, rudimentary
capabilities still,
organizational
command and control
is not as mature in either
country as in the Cold
War, especially in the later
years the Cold War obviously.
But the other big difference
is they border each other.
So the flight times
between India and Pakistan
is on the order of
a couple minutes.
The US and Soviet
Union was 30 minutes.
So you had a half hour to
figure what was going on.
In India and Pakistan,
you have two minutes--
if you had any early warning--
and early warning systems are
very rudimentary-- if you
had any early warning,
or indication that the
other side is launching
a potential nuclear strike,
you have two minutes
before that thing
is going to hit.
So your reaction times
have to be much quicker.
The other big difference
is-- I'm going
to skip through this here.
The other big difference
is, as you mentioned,
why would India be interested
in conventional attacks
against Pakistan?
Well, it wouldn't be
ab-- it wouldn't be
the first to initiate conflict.
The Indian problem
right now is it
is facing a Pakistan that is
more aggressively emboldened
to launch militant attacks
in India using organization--
proxy organization
sponsored by the state--
or believed to be
sponsored by the state,
like Lushkar-e-Taiba,
Jaish-e-Mohammed.
And the strategy has
changed since Pakistan
tested nuclear weapons.
Prior to 1998, Pakistan--
there was a strategy,
coined by Zia and
General Aslam Baig,
known as bleeding
India by 1,000 cuts.
So there's a strategy of
cutting India at the periphery.
In the line of control in
Jammu Kashmir in the mountains,
you couldn't have a real
conventional battle,
but you could have
terrorist infiltration.
There would be some attacks
and just small cuts.
But the strategy has shifted
since 1998, it seems.
The frequency of
over infiltration
by regular forces in
the Kargil War in 1999
and then multiple attacks on
Indian metropolitan cities
with these Pakistan-based
militant organizations.
It leads to a
condition where India
wouldn't be starting a war,
but it would be retaliating.
So India's mainstay threat
prior to nuclearization
was if you try the strategy of
bleeding us by a thousand cuts,
we're going to punish
you where it hurts.
We're going to
destroy your army.
If you're an army led state,
an army controlled state,
we'll cross the
international border,
and we will attrit your army.
And that will punish Pakistan.
So that was the deterrence
by punishment strategy
India had at the conventional
level prior to nuclearization.
But post-nuclearization
now Pakistan is doing what?
It threatens-- well, it's going
to stand and fight for a while.
But in extreme, it threatens
tactical nuclear use
on Indian forces if
India tries to retaliate
across the international border.
And so that's the scenario
that India finds itself now.
And that's the
scenario in which India
would think about conventional
conflict with Pakistan.
It's not for
territorial ambition
or any territorial gains.
It would be for retaliation
after a provocation.
So there are a couple examples.
The first is the Kargil War.
Does anyone remember
this, May 1999?
So this was a year after
they tested nuclear weapons.
General Pervez Musharraf,
who ended up being president
during the first phase of
the Afghan war in 2000-- this
was right before September--
two years before September 11.
Nawaz Sharif-- man history
does repeat itself.
Nawaz Sharif was then
the prime minister.
He is again the prime
minister today by the way.
He claims he had no
knowledge of this operation.
But then General
Pervez Musharraf,
who was the chief of army
staff, orchestrated an operation
where un-uniformed regular
Pakistan forces, known
as the Northern Light Infiltry--
the Northern Light Infantry,
infiltrated into several sectors
in to Indian held Kashmir,
into Indian territory.
And India responded
with trying to dislodge
the Pakistani forces.
Previously, this exact operation
had been attempted in 1965.
India launched air strikes
across the line of control
and opened a second front
across the international border.
This, time the BJP
responded very differently.
Because of Pakistan's
nuclearization,
the BJP was much more restrained
and sustained heavier losses
because the threat of
escalating the conflict
deterred the BJP from
the same kind of response
that it had in 1965--
that India had.
So it refused to
allow air operations
across the line of control.
So Indian aircraft could not
cross the line of control
in hot pursuit of
Pakistsani infiltrators.
And most importantly,
they did not
threaten to open up
the second front.
The place where India's
conventional advantage really
comes to bear is on the
international border, here.
So most of the
fighting was here.
This was where the
infiltration was.
But India has a huge advantage
in this plane sector, which
is the international border.
So any time there has been
a previous provocation,
India has always mobilized
forces here and threatened
to open up a second
front where it can really
bring its conventional
power to bear on Pakistan.
This time, the BJP
refused to threaten
to open-- it did
not mobilize any
of its mainstay
conventional forces
on the international
border and didn't threaten
to open up a second front.
And so it took Indian
forces a lot longer,
and they sustained much heavier
losses in the Kargil War,
because they had to expel
Pakistani forces symmetrically.
So they didn't have the
virtue of air power hitting
behind Pakistani lines.
And there wasn't any ability to
take pressure off of this front
by opening up a second front
in the international border.
So already you can see
India's response is restrained
because Pakistan
was a nuclear power.
So shortly after September
11 here, two months later--
three months later,
there was an attack
on the Indian parliament.
So you had about half
a dozen gunman break
through the barriers of the
Indian Parliament house.
I mean imagine an
attack on Congress here.
It would be the equivalent.
So you had Jaish-e-Mohammed and
Lushkar-e-Taiba joint attack
on the Indian
parliament in Delhi.
Never heard of before that
they-- these militant groups,
which are nominally supported
by the Pakistani state,
would attack the Indian capital.
So you had this
attack in December.
The BJP is furious.
Imagine what the
United States would
do if a militant organization
attacked the US Congress.
So you can imagine the
outrage in India at the time.
So the BJP contemplates
limited war here
across the line of control,
so destroying terrorist camps
across the line of control.
Under a lot of pressure
from the US government
because remember
what's happened?
We were mobilizing for war
on Afghanistan at this point.
We need Pakistan.
The United States
needs General Musharraf
to not be distracted by a
conventional war with India.
Can you imagine how that
would have affected the US
war in Afghanistan if
India and Pakistan got
into a conventional
war at the time.
So a lot of pressure on
both sides to not go to war.
So Deputy Secretary of State
at the time, Dick Armitage,
gets on the phone.
He's on the phone, he said,
twice a day with the BJP
urging them to show restraint.
And India backs off
actually for a while.
But then there's
a secondary attack
in a small town called
Kaluchack in Jammu,
which is an army town.
And the Jaish militants killed
36 Indian army families.
And so the BJP, at
this point-- this
is the second peak
of the crisis.
And so the BJP says
enough is enough.
So they mobilize India's three--
they call them the three Strike
Corps.
These are the main offensive
components of the Indian army.
800,000 forces in total.
And they're mobilized in
their assembly boxes, which
are much larger than shown
here, 60 kilometer breadth,
in these three positions,
poised for attacks
across the international border.
So this is where
the threat of war
becomes real for South Asia.
SO the BJP, you don't mobilize
these forces just as a bluff.
And so there's a real
concern that the BJP
would authorize attacks.
And at this point,
Pakistan engages
in some serious nuclear signal.
They test three nuclear
capable missiles,
without the warheads of course.
President Musharraf makes
very explicit nuclear threats
to the Indians that if they
cross the international border
that Pakistan may have no option
but to use nuclear weapons.
The US and the United
Kingdom evacuate
their nonessential
personnel from India.
I mean it was very
serious at this point.
After these nuclear
threats, and again,
a lot of pressure from the
United States on India,
Prime Minister Vajpayee
orders, several months later,
the Strike Corps back to their
peacetime cantonments, which
are in the interior of India.
And later on, he
said, look, I don't
think that a risk of
nuclear war was high,
but I didn't want to be
responsible for starting one.
And so there was a
real palpable threat
that if India engaged in this
kind of conventional operation
against Pakistan and
defeated the Pakistan army,
that there's a real risk that
nuclear weapons would be used.
The third instance was
the Bombay attack in 2008
that we already talked
about at the beginning.
So here, this was even more
audacious, in some ways,
than the parliament attack.
This wasn't a ragtag group
of six guys in a car.
This was a dozen well-trained,
heavily armed militants coming
by sea from Karachi,
quarterbacked-- it now turns
out-- by retired ISI handlers.
The United States picked
up signals intelligence
and intercepts between
handlers in Pakistan
who were former ISI officers
quarterbacking the operation
as they attacked Bombay.
And it killed 170 civilians.
So the media tends to downplay
the number of Westerners that
were deliberately
targeted by the militant--
by the LeT militants.
And India was justifiably
outraged at this attack.
But the government
was again paralyzed.
So this time it's the
Congress government
not the BJP government
that's making decisions.
And it doesn't mobilize
forces this time.
The prime minister,
Mahmud Hussein,
said he did not want a
repeat of 2001, 2002.
We don't want to mobilize
forces and not do anything.
So what do we do?
And here we have the paralysis
that the Indian policy
community faces is any serious
conventional retaliation risks
nuclear escalation.
I think this is where
India finds itself.
And this is from
a cabinet meeting.
So this is a report
from the cabinet meeting
where the prime
minister and the defense
minister, foreign minister,
finance minister, home minister
are meeting.
And the conclusion was,
when the dust settled,
all the principles agreed
that the unpredictability
on the Pakistan side and the
fear that its decision-makers
could offer a disproportionate
response, including
the nuclear option,
stymied any possible chance
of military action on India'a
behalf after-- 26/11 is their--
is what they call
the Bombay attacks.
It happened on the
26th of November.
So there's real
paralysis now about how
do you deter-- see
nuclear weapons can't
deter militant attacks
against the Indian state.
But you lost your
conventional option
to punish Pakistan,
which was how you tried
to deter it in the first place.
And Pakistan has
successfully deterred
Indian a conventional power by
lowering the nuclear threshold,
taking a play right out
of the NATO playbook,
threatening early nuclear use if
Indian forces threaten to cross
the international border.
So now, after
nuclearization 1998,
what we have is more
frequent and intense
crises triggered by Pakistan.
There's a belief that
they're emboldened
by the shield of
early nuclear use,
knowing that India can't really
retaliate with ground power.
We can get into-- we have
some time for questions.
We can get into why India hasn't
tried to develop an air strike
option.
That gets into the politics
of the Indian military--
the service rivalries
that India has.
The Air Force has always
refused to think about options
that don't involve
the army mobilizing
because the belief is that
Pakistan would retaliate
on the ground.
And so the Air Force doesn't
believe that standalone air
options are possible without a
ground option being mobilized.
AUDIENCE: So what
is Pakistan trying
to achieve with these attacks?
VIPIN NARANG: So this is an
interesting strategic question.
What does Pakistan hope--
so if your Pakistan,
you're facing a
conventional-- you're
facing massive conventional
inferiority, which is only
growing because the size
and growth rates of the two
countries are so
disproportionate that India's
gap is just going-- it's
going to be a yawning
gap at this point.
So going forward, how
do you slow India down?
So there's one theory
out there, which
is these periodic attacks on
India's financial and political
hubs create these
periodic crises to get
foreign investors skittish.
So you get periodic slowdowns
being triggered by this,
and you can slow down
India's economic growth
potential if you make it
risky to invest in India.
So that's one theory out there.
The other theory is Pakistan
has always had crazies
that is trained to attack.
Good crazies kill Indians.
Bad crazies kill Pakistanis.
And so they need-- there's
a safety valve theory.
And they've always
had a safety valve.
Before it was Kashmir.
Now, Kashmir is locked
down because Indian army
knows how to prevent
infiltration at Kashmir.
For a while, it was Afghanistan.
US military has to be asked,
why are these guys speaking
Punjabi in Afghanistan?
Because these are the Punjabi
trained militants, the LeT,
that have gone now to
Afghanistan to fight,
and they're killing Americans.
And now if you can turn them
against the Indian state,
great.
As long as they're not
killing Pakistanis,
they are good militants.
And so there's one
theory out there
that the Pakistan state still
views these militant groups
as strategic assets
of the states
to perpetually attack and
bleed India by 1,000 cuts.
And if you can't get
in through Kashmir,
if you could infiltrate
by sea to Bombay, great.
If you can hit Delhi, great.
Before nuclear weapons,
hitting Bombay or Delhi
really risked serious
conventional retaliation.
But now that you
have nuclear weapons
and operational
nuclear capability
and tactical nuclear
weapons to deter
that conventional
retaliation, those kinds
of audacious attacks
are more possible.
And so these are the two
kind of theories out there,
and they're not
mutually exclusive.
AUDIENCE: What [INAUDIBLE]
in Afghanistan.
What are they called
the thieves, the rebels,
or whatever-- they were fighting
[INAUDIBLE] in Afghanistan?
VIPIN NARANG: I mean I think
that there are people here
who can say more
about this who had
firsthand experience with this.
But there are a lot of reports
that you had Punjabi speaking.
I mean most of the Afghan
mujahideen are Pashto speaking.
There's a Haqqani network.
A lot of these
networks predate 9/11.
And they were supported,
funded, and there
are strong relationships
between the ISI
and some of the mujahideen
groups in Afghanistan that
ended up being the Taliban--
remember the only two
states that recognized
the Taliban were
Pakistan, Saudi Arabia.
So the networks that
Pakistan had in Afghanistan
were very strong.
And they had these
other groups also,
so if they needed militants
to go help fight what ended up
being the Americans as
well as Karzai's ANA,
it would be the LeT and
the Jaish-e-Mohammeds.
So there were reports of
Punjabi speaking militants,
well-trained Punjabi
speaking militants,
fighting in Afghanistan
alongside Pashto
speaking Haqqani
network militants.
So that was a safety
valve for a while.
And now, I think
this is why Pakistan
may have an
incentive for a fight
to continue in
Afghanistan for a while
so it has someplace
to send its crazies.
It's a safety valve for a while.
And they're worried about
Indian influence in Afghanistan
so that there would
be-- those militants
would be boxed into Pakistan.
On the one hand,
Pakistan faces--
there was this awful
school attack recently.
There's a real terrorist
problem in Pakistan also.
So bad militants
kill Pakistanis.
Good militants kill
Indians and Americans.
Steph?
AUDIENCE: I was going
to ask that question as
to whether [INAUDIBLE]
are all bad.
But initially, that
comes out maybe
to supporting the
militants out there.
Do you think that that is--
that initial rhetoric is
going to stick?
Or do you think they
will then go back
to what they've
always done which
is we're going to support
whoever destablizes people
we don't like?
VIPIN NARANG: So I think the
evidence suggests the latter.
I mean it is remarkable that
the LeT-- so after 2001, 2000,
the LeT was nominally banned.
But they just renamed
themselves to Jamaat-ud-Dawa.
And Hafiz Saeed who is
the head of the LeT lives
openly, not out in
the tribal areas.
He lives outside Lahore
in a town called Muridke.
Everybody knows where they are.
They're openly fund-raising.
He goes on TV calling for
the death of Indians openly.
And the fact that he--
it's an open question
whether it's active
support or passive support.
But at least the evidence
suggest-- the evidence suggests
at least passive support.
He is allowed to freely operate.
He is allowed to
freely raise funds.
The organization exists.
It could be shut
down very easily.
It's in the heart of Pakistan.
It's like 30 kilometers
from the Indian border.
The Indians could hit it.
But they have refrained
from doing so.
But the network is allowed to
recruit and operate openly.
And we're not talking about like
the Northwest Front, the Khyber
Pakhtunkhwa, the tribal areas.
This is the heartland
of Pakistan.
And so it offends credibility
to think that it's not--
there isn't some state policy to
allow certain groups to operate
to some extent while thinking
you could target the rest.
But there's also that suggests
these guys were different hats
on different days.
But the sectarian groups, I
think, are allowed to operate.
Those are the ones that--
the other good militants seem
to be those that kill Shia.
As long as they don't
kill Sunni, it's fine.
So some of those groups
have been very, very fierce
and are allowed
to operate still.
In the Haqqani
network and the LeT,
as long as they're not
killing Sunnis in Punjab,
it seems like the
Pakistani state
is willing to tolerate
their existence.
And so that's an
active state policy.
And this is different
from the Cold War.
We didn't have-- I don't
think the United States
and the Soviet Union had to deal
with that kind of proxy level
militancy where you have
two strategic assets.
You have the militant
organizations
to try and weaken the other
state plus nuclear weapons
to deter the retaliation.
So that combination
is, I think, what
makes it particularly dangerous,
which is what I conclude here.
So you have-- India is
extremely frustrated.
And I think the worry
in the United States
is that if there's another
mass casualty terrorist
attack in India, how
will the BJP-- now
you have a new prime minister
who is, by all accounts,
a little more aggressive than
his predecessors, a little more
hawkish.
And right now, the
stability in South Asia
is predicated on Indian
restraint following
one of these mass casualty
terrorist attacks.
So if there's another Bombay,
how will the BJP respond?
We can talk-- if anybody
has heard of Cold Start,
we talk about that.
You guys can all email
me if anyone ever wants
to get into some of the weeds.
But the basic idea is India
has conventional superiority.
It has not used it yet.
There's some belief that
Pakistan's nuclear threat is
a bluff and that
India could execute
certain conventional objectives
below the nuclear threshold.
Maybe, maybe not.
It's pretty risky.
Particularly, we talk about
tactical nuclear weapons
that would, at
least at some point,
be devolved to the
brigadier level maybe.
And so you'll have-- it's not
just one nuclear threshold,
but nine.
And so you have
to worry about one
of them deciding
that this is the end,
and they use nuclear weapons.
I think the Pakistani strategy
is actually quite rational.
It's deterring with
the rational threatened
that we might use
tactical nuclear weapons,
but also through a
madman mechanism.
We're going to develop
nuclear weapons,
and hey, one of our brigadiers
might use them if you come.
And that reinforces the rational
deterrent threat as well.
And so, so far, both
in Kargil-- sorry.
In three instances, Kargil,
Parakram, and Bombay,
India has relatively restrained
its conventional retaliation
and its response.
And so far, that has
taken India and Pakistan
off the escalatory highway.
But it's no guarantee that
that'll continue going forward.
I think the emotions in India
are running very high vis-a-vis
Pakistan.
Particularly, there's
increased shelling
across the line of control
in the past several months.
And if there's a significant
attack in a major city that
involves the death of
many Indian civilians,
there'll be a lot of pressure
on Prime Minister Modi
to do something about it.
And then all bets are
off because you'll
have nuclear weapons
potentially mixed
with conventional
conflict, and that
would be the escalation ladder.
I think that's
something that we're
likely-- it's this element of
terrorist attack mass casualty
terrorist attacks that didn't
exist in the Cold War, that
makes South Asia quite
different, I think,
from the US and Soviet balance.
And so it's that
combination of proxy forces
and the arms race that, I think,
makes it particularly unstable.
So I'm going to stop there.
We are almost out
of time, but I'm
happy to take
questions for a while
if anybody has any further
thoughts or anything.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does Pakistan
have strategic weapons aimed
at Indian cities or--
VIPIN NARANG: It does.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --weapon
also reach [INAUDIBLE].
VIPIN NARANG: Yeah.
So this gets into a concept
known as escalation dominance.
Pakistan also has
strategic weapons
that put most of India's
matrices in reach.
The idea being that that
deters Indian retaliation
for tactical
nuclear-- so Pakistan
views tactical nuclear
use as a war terminating
strategy because of
the strategic weapons.
So the idea is if any
conventional forces
attack, Pakistan stands
and fights conventionally.
Fine.
They start losing.
They use tactical nuclear
weapons on Indian forces.
But now I have a secure
second strike capability
also if I'm Pakistan.
So India has no incentive to use
its strategic nuclear weapons
against Pakistani cities because
nuclear use on your forces
operating on Pakistani soil,
that's already happened.
Am I willing to risk Delhi
and Bombay for retaliating.
Probably not.
Now absent the strategic
capabilities, you're right.
Then, India could
easily retaliate,
and there would be no
reciprocation from Pakistan.
But Pakistan is
trying to establish
what it calls escalation
dominance so that it could
use tactical nuclear
weapons, and that
would be the end of it.
So India would have no
incentive to retaliate
with strategic nuclear
weapons against Pakistan.
There is some belief
that India's looking
at lower order use options.
India has no tactical
nuclear weapons itself.
But there are some
capabilities that
could be used for softer
targets than just cities.
And it may be that
India tries to develop
tit-for-tat capabilities.
And then that's basically your
escalation ladder as well.
In the back?
AUDIENCE: So if
India is so paralyzed
and Pakistan realizes
this, why hasn't Pakistan
increase the
frequency of attack?
VIPIN NARANG: I think part of
it is you can't do it too often.
You do it too often, and
then the core world opinion--
I think there's a limit to
how often you can do it.
But once every two, three
years is not nothing.
And there's always chatter.
There have been several
instances where the Indian home
ministry claims-- now, I don't
know how good the evidence is--
that they've disrupted several
attacks by LeT on Indians--
on India.
But every several years, I
think that's not nothing.
And they also choose relatively
strategic moments to do it.
So if you look at the timing of
the attack on the parliament,
two months after 9/11, just as
the Pakistani US relationship
is growing again.
Maybe there's a belief
you can get away
with it because the US
is going to protect you.
The Bombay attack was just
as then President Musharraf
was-- there was discussion
of concluding a back channel
final agreement over Kashmir.
And the LeT and the
India-focused militants
acted as veto
players, as spoilers.
And so there was
a comp-- something
known as the composite
dialogue ongoing between India
and Pakistan in 2008 where
literally everybody knew
what the final solution peace
deal between India and Pakistan
would like.
And President Musharraf
was very serious about it.
This was spoilers within
Pakistan vetoing that deal
and disrupting the dialogue.
So India had no option
but to terminate
the composite
dialogue after Bombay.
And it hasn't really restarted.
And so those strategic
moments, I think,
are chosen by Pakistani
militants to attack India.
Yes, sir?
So what's the story-- I've heard
bits and pieces about Khan.
How did he evolve?
Where did he come from?
What was--
VIPIN NARANG: Yes, so that's
a whole other-- AQ Khan,
he stole the designs.
He provided the uranium
enrichment capability
to Pakistan.
He orchestrated a network
of global suppliers
for the components
for the centrifuges,
which he then leveraged
for both state policy.
So he used that network
to get North Korea
its centrifuge capability.
But whether, with complicit
state support or acting
on his own, he also
decided to make
some money by moonlighting,
maybe, with Iran and Libya.
And there's believed to
be a fourth customer.
Don't know who that is.
But there's a big debate also in
the Pakistan nuclear community
about how influential
AQ Khan really was.
I mean they're moving to the
plutonium designs anyway.
PAEC, which is the Pakistan
Atomic Energy Commission.
They're responsible for
plutonium production pathway.
They're competing for
designs and for ownership
of the Pakistani program.
So in Pakistan, he
still-- he claims
to be the father of
the Pakistani bomb.
That's up for dispute.
But some of the
proliferation activities, it
is unclear whether they
were state sponsored
or whether there was
some state complicity,
and he just acted on his own
or whether he acted completely
on his own.
AUDIENCE: But he served this
thing, I mean is it true?
I mean did he have this
business that basically
sells nuclear technology to
anyone who will pay the money?
VIPIN NARANG: I
mean, like I said-- I
mean he-- there was a catalog.
You could get a
brochure for-- yeah.
And so it is true
that there was--
he definitely had really
significant dealings
with Iran, which is interesting
because Iran and Pakistan
aren't natural allies--
are the ones who made Shia,
Sunni-- they're not natural.
Iran has also been involved
with the Balochistan insurgency
in Pakistan.
So that he would sell
centrifuges to Iran
seems a little puzzling.
May be it was for-- seems
like personal gain would
be a very strong explanation.
There's some evidence
that he approached Iraq
in the late 1980s to see if
they're interested in uranium
enrichment.
Saddam Hussein thought it was
a trap, so he passed on it.
But, yeah, I mean
there's no question
that there was-- this is a
big nonproliferation failure.
AUDIENCE: I can't
remember if I read
about it on [INAUDIBLE]
media or [INAUDIBLE],
but I remember
reading about this.
And what they said was that he
was doing it for personal gain.
VIPIN NARANG: Yeah, there's no
question he made a lot of money
from it.
But you would have to
leverage some assets
from Pakistan military
to do some of this stuff.
There's no way that they
didn't-- some people
didn't know about unless
they were in on the take,
which is entirely possible.
I mean I find it hard--
certainly the North
Korean deal, I mean they
flew Pakistani C-17,
so it was military transport
that took the first centrifuge
cascade over to North Korea.
So that was definitely
state to state.
Some of the other
stuff is just really
murky as to the level
of state complicity.
Were there people in
the Pakistan government
who knew he was doing it.
I'd probably-- it would be hard
for me to believe that they
didn't.
But it may not have
been state policy.
Yes, sir?
Last question, I
think, then we got to--
So I think that the
influence of the US support
is, perhaps, understated.
If we ignored Pakistan,
didn't like them anymore,
and the entire international
community turned on them,
it might be devastating
for them, especially
economic sanctions [INAUDIBLE].
VIPIN NARANG: So we imposed
sanctions after 1998.
But then after September
11, we needed Pakistan.
AUDIENCE: How long
will we need them?
[INAUDIBLE]
VIPIN NARANG: There are a
couple good books on this
out recently.
I'm not a Pakistan expert.
And this gets into very
like-- the empirical evidence
for this is-- we don't know.
But Pakistan could
be very vulnerable.
I mean I think a nontrivial
proportion of their revenue
comes from US and
international aid.
But on the other hand,
given the militancy problem,
I think most countries
prefer a stable Pakistan
to an unstable Pakistan.
And heavy sanctions
could really disrupt
the fabric of that state.
And say so it's a very
thin line you walk.
And part of it is, I think the
opportunity that the United
States had was in the 1980s.
And there was a belief in
the Reagan administration
that it was one or the other.
It was either we needed to
Pakistan against the Sovs
or it's the nuclear program.
But we couldn't deal with
both at the same time.
The United states wasn't happy.
It wasn't like the US was happy
about the Pakistani nuclear
program.
But it is certainly
true that the executive
was willing to
look the other way
and tolerate certain
movement up to a point,
probably on the belief
that it was inevitable.
There's nothing much
you can do about it.
I'm not sure if that's true.
I actually think that there were
a lot of leverage points we--
the United States could
have had in the 1980s
and didn't take
advantage of them.
But that's also--
an administration
fighting this war may not
believe it has the bandwidth
to deal with both.
And I think that's
where they ended up.
But if there was ever a point,
it was probably in the 1980s
to stop Pakistan from
becoming a nuclear state
in the first place.
But now that they
are, it's really hard
to see what we can do.
Aaron, yeah?
AUDIENCE: There is an overall
question here, which is tough.
I mean it's a very
unstable situation
between India and Pakistan.
And you either keep
going from them
leading the way it has been
going, or you take a big step.
And the big step
is either you're
going to do something
war-like or peace-like.
And there is a
peace-like thing which
never seems to surface,
which is, look,
if you can't solve
this by war-like steps,
then you have to solve
it by eliminating
the political tension.
And that doesn't seem
to be possible in India.
India is this world power,
and why don't they stand up--
what's your analysis?
Why don't they stand
up and say, we're
not going to solve this
militarily so we better--
VIPIN NARANG: I think there
was a real golden opportunity
in 2008.
I think Manmohan Singh and then
foreign secretary Shivshankar
Menon who's going to
be at MIT actually
in February at the Center
for National Studies with us,
he can give more
insight on this.
But I believe India was
ready to do that in 2008.
And Musharraf was ready
to do this in 2008.
Certain elements of the
Pakistani security services
and their proxy forces
and the LeT were not.
And so it was just
politically untenable,
after the Bombay attack, for
the Indian political leadership.
And so the spoilers--
the spoilers spoiled.
AUDIENCE: They spoiled
it, but the point
is that that was the
point to stand up,
and probably again
because you're in a bind.
VIPIN NARANG: But I
mean the politics of it
was just too-- I
mean there's just
no way that that
government could
have survived if it continued
with a composite dialogue.
And it was also a case
where there were facing--
elections were the next year.
There was no way that the
composite dialogue could
have continued after bombing.
No country could do that.
No political leadership could.
It's just unfortunate-- the
unfortunate nature of politics.
And I think the LeT knew that.
You perpetrate this
attack, and you
will kill the composite dialogue
and the back channel talk.
And that's exactly
what happened.
It may be-- it's interesting
because sometimes you
need a Nixon and
China moment, and Modi
who is hawkish in the BJP,
he has the credibility
to get the right on his side.
He's protect on his right
flank, which often tends
to be the spoiler in India.
So he has an
opportunity, I think.
And I wouldn't be surprised if
there's some movement toward it
in the administration provided
there are no other attacks.
So I think you're right.
All the piecess--
everybody knows
what the final deal looks like.
There's one hiccup
about whether it's
sequential or simultaneous
demilitarization
of the Siachen [INAUDIBLE]
or like minor things.
I mean those are solvable.
But everything else,
the line of control
becomes a de facto
national border.
Everything else
gets adjudicated.
And maybe-- Modi has five
years, so it's possible.
If anyone in India
can do it, I think
it has to be somebody
from the right.
The question is whether
there's a willing partner--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
VIPIN NARANG: --willing
partners on Pakistan.
Exactly.
OK, I think we're over time.
So we should-- I gotta pick
up my kid from daycare,
so thank you guys.
Thanks!